hey David if other countries are so
great as liberals like to say why don't
more liberals move there first question
is what do you mean by there because a
lot of places are difficult to move to
right and of course when you explain
that to the right they will say that's
why the places are doing well because
they don't just allow anybody in but I
actually think that that's a distortion
of the argument most people on the left
and right who threatened to move if this
happens or that happens or point out
that this place is better in one respect
or that place is better in another
respect most of them have family and
have a life in the United States and
it's not actually that easy to just get
up and move psychologically emotionally
aside from legally and aside from
language barriers and aside from from
questions of what it is that you would
do for work and I think that this is
what the right doesn't get when they
talk about immigration right they talk
about immigration like it is this thing
that people from other countries just do
on a whim to come and use the resources
of the United States and get on welfare
and consume our electricity and what you
know whatever dumb arguments they make
it offends your life I did it right when
I was five years old I moved from
Argentina to the United States the
effects of which still inform sort of my
personality and who I am right now and
it was like sort of a irreversible
impact to do that the idea that these
are small decisions is seems to be
completely over the heads of many of the
people on the right who say things like
that
so there's lots of reasons why other
countries can be better in certain ways
and people still wouldn't go there right
like work family immigration whatever
and it's just kind of a dumb argument
even make if it's so great why don't you
go there I've never okay bought into the
love it or leave it mentality I think
it's pretty flawed I mean I understand
that America has a great number of
problems but I love this country so much
that they want to I want to improve them
and what you love about it oh I don't
know I've still have to think about it's
like the culture the geographical
diversity the history to it yeah God I
mean the fact that you have people who
live here from all different walks of
life
yes it's truly
unique place on this earth doesn't mean
we don't have problems right we're very
we ranked very low in education and
healthcare and all these things but I
think we can't ameliorate those problems
but you have to admit that the cafe
culture of Europe definitely is
something that's missing in the United
States well you will you agree to that
I'll concede that point yes yeah but
there are other things to this country
that I like what's better about the US
then about every other place come up
with something that I'd a few things
there I said geographical diverse parts
of places have it I said I won't know I
mean you got like you got mountains you
got desert Argentina grasslands you've
got you beautiful national parks so
Argentina has everything from Antarctic
to desert to mountain to flatland
to jungle to forests no I think we got
everything I think we got everything
color and we got we've got the
rainforest - you talked about like even
Hawaii or whatever else yeah be
immigration lots of countries have
immigration did you hate America is this
what this comes down I think what you're
getting to is that there is a sort of
janessa quoi that is an indefinable
something that encompasses what America
is in total that appeals to you and it
makes you interested in maintaining your
status as a part of the project of
America so let's just keep it at genesee
quoi we don't have to that's fine the
exact terms then that's fine it's a
really dumb question if other countries
are so great why don't more liberals
move there and by the way I know lots of
liberals who have moved I have a lot of
friends now who basically just live in
Europe right like they've decided that
they were gonna do graduate school there
and then by doing that they were able to
get internships which led to job offers
and even in places with relatively
strict immigration they now have
permanent residency and and they live
there they are what are called expats
which is a very politically loaded term
if you're white and American and you
move somewhere else you're an expat if
you're brown and foreign from the US and
moved to the US you're not an expat from
your source country you're an immigrant
and according to troy york in our
voicemail segment last week an invader a
subhuman invader he had the audacity to
say that's why if i was to leave this
country i would also have to change my
name because I can't be an expat named
Pat it just would just wouldn't work
nobody
have to go by your middle name Leland
and that would be very concerning to a
lot of people okay that is it for today
great bonus show for you today
that's all I have to say we'll talk to
you on the bonus show